das ist hannah hanna wird einmal eine
emanzipierte frau
ob sie auch mutter werden wird
wie jedes mädchen ist hanna mit gut zwei
millionen eizellen auf die welt gekommen
in der pubertät sind nur noch 200.000
üblich und wenn sie mit 40 mutter werden
will wird es bereits knapp so manche
frau hat sie schon verflucht diese
ticken der biologische uhr
zum glück leben wir im jahr 2015
es gibt lösungen für vieles auch dafür
wie frau ihren kinderwunsch auf später
verschieben kann zum beispiel mit social
freezing reife eizellen werden
eingefroren und haltbar gemacht um
später befruchtet zu werden ein
scheinbarer triumph für die
gleichberechtigung der geschlechter
margrit stamm ist renommierte
erziehungswissenschaftler hin
ihr weg war untypisch mit 27 wurde sie
mutter mit 35 erst fing sie ein studium
an ihr mann unterstützte sie aus ihrem
umfeld kam jedoch harsche kritik
mit 48 habilitierte sie dann für sie ist
social freezing kein gewinn für die
emanzipation damit sehr problematisch
dass man eigentlich wti versteckt die
botschaft der freiheit und übermittle
liebe frauen mutterschaft und karriere
geht nicht leitet verschiebt das auf
später das von mir als vegetarier
entwickeln wir weitergeben mutterschaft
und karriere kölner zusammen miteinander
und mit einer gesellschaft wo sich
verändert dass sie familie finden wird
richtig weiter entwickeln die
fortpflanzungsmedizin gibt den takt vor
1960 die antibabypille schluss mit der
formel sechs gleich baby endlich kann
frau bewusst mit dem scheiß
1978 das erste baby ohne sex gezeigt in
der petrischale und heute ewige jugend
für unsere eizellen die neue losung baby
ohne sex und viel später
wenn die rushhour des lebens sie tobt
zwischen 30 und 40 karriere planen und
machen
beziehung finden und pflegen
kinder gebären und aufziehen
über allem thronte eiskalte imperativ du
kannst alles haben also musst du auch
alles ist mach und planbar
kann frau sich dem entziehen wie lautet
sie eigentlich diese biologische uhr gar
nicht behauptet sarah die die 36 jährige
hat ein buch darüber geschrieben wieso
frauen sich gegen nachwuchs entscheiden
weil sie unabhängig und frei sein wollen
wie sie selbst
ich habe tatsächlich glaube ich einfach
nie mein leben jetzt mit kinder kriegen
oder mutterschaft verbunden also es war
einfach nie so teil von meiner
vorstellung von meinem frau sein
kinderlosigkeit nicht zuletzt als ausweg
als alternative zur scheinbaren idylle
der kleinfamilie zur hohen
scheidungsrate gegen das traditionelle
rollen denken
ich glaube das ist glaube ich generell
einfach das große missverständnis wenn
man über gleichberechtigung spricht oder
frauen die man situation dass man immer
denkt okay also das ist im grunde
erreicht wenn die frauen das machen
können was männer tun können das reicht
eben nicht sondern männer müssen auch
das tun was frauen tun nämlich
pflegearbeit haushalt kinderbetreuung
kinder haben oder mit kindern
zusammenleben müssen
gesamtgesellschaftliches projekt sein
und eben nicht immer nur auf die frau
abgeschoben werden das fordert auch
margrit stamm und plädiert für ausgleich
anstatt es social freezing wird die
meeres work freezing vorschwebe dass man
apple die strangs die phase wird die
familienphase ist dass mittäter die eu
fluggerät das zum beispiel ältere sich
mehr der familie widmen und dass man
auch am karriereschritt sportplatz dass
man das mit über dank dass ich einfach
abstrus dass man mit 40 eigentlich muss
karriere gemacht hat
also hanna schlaf du nur
wir brauchen noch eine weile um das
problem zu lösen